June, are you ready to hit the headlines with us?
Oh God, could not be more ready.
You are up baby,
you are up.
So Drew, first up,
we've got a very strong statement
that has just come out from Kim Kardashian.
She has said that she would wear an adult diaper
if fashion demanded it.
Oh wow.
"Insider" reports, "Kim has not actually worn a diaper
"for high fashion yet,
"but she has squeezed into dresses that have prevented her
"from peeing for four hours
"and made it so that she could not sit down at dinner."
Thoughts?
I mean, has anyone worn a romper?
It's miserable to go to the bathroom.
You're sitting on the toilet naked as a jay bird,
awfully, awfully vulnerable.
And that does not look as easy to get out of as a romper.
It sounds like you'd do it.
I just like that she would say something like this.
I am titillated
by Kim Kardashian being like,
"Listen, anything for fashion."
I love it.
I'm like, you're gonna make adult diapers cool.
I'm just curious how this came up in conversation.
Someone's talking with Kim and like,
"Oh, I meant to ask you,
"would you ever wear a diaper?"
But good for her.
At least she's pampering herself.
All right, next up,
2022 is shaping up to be a weddings bonanza.
Everyone is getting married this year.
Hey, yah, I am too.
Welly and I are part of the happy grooms.
(audience clap)
But it feels like there's so many weddings.
There was like a hole during the pandemic
when you couldn't really do it, you couldn't gather
so I know people are back.
And "The New York Times" reports,
"There will be 2.5 million weddings this year alone
"which is the highest number since 1984."
And some of the wedding trends are going back
to the '80s.
Experts say, "We're gonna see huge, epic 80 style gowns."
You remember that, with all the tulle.
And then over the top wedding cakes as well.
What do you think
about this trend going big for your wedding again?
Well notice they said since the '80s,
that was when Princess Diana had her wedding
and changed everything.
It changed the wedding industry as we know it.
And I also discovered a story to compliment this one.
And it's proof that you can get a maximal wedding
by paying minimal bucks.
"USA Today" reports that,
"Kiara and Joel, newlyweds from Los Angeles are going viral
"for their low cost wedding."
They got married on a beautiful California cliff side
for a grand total of $500.
The wedding dress itself was $47.
And Kiara said her mindset was,
"Why spend a lot for a dress I'm gonna wear once?"
And congratulations to Kiara and Joel
because some people opulence and they find it worth it
to spend all their money on this big day.
Some people do not have that option or even do
and just don't have that kind of mindset.
They're more frugal.
So I love this minimalist, maximalist approach.
You do what's right for you.
All options are awesome.
Absolutely, if you wanna go big, go big.
I love that they got it in $500.
I'm planning a wedding right now.
I'm telling you, a guy would love to do it for $500.
Oh, I've met your wedding planner.
That ain't happening?
He's a little bit like Franc
from "Father of the Bride"!
"Father of the Bride"!
My favorite Martin Short character.
My God!
Oh my God.
He had more bling on his body.
He sent me a bouquet of flowers that they wheeled in, Ross.
And I was like, "Oh my God."
You're gonna wanna top up more zeros on that.
I don't wanna think about it,
but I will tell you this.
It is a special day.
Go big or go small, it's your day.
Up next, how red hot is the housing market right now?
If you look at prices, they're crazy.
And this one caught our attention.
It's a four bedroom in Virginia,
complete with strangers living in the basement.
Yes, it just sold for over asking.
Yahoo reports the house literally described
as needing $25,000 in repairs for leaks and rot,
went for over $800,000 in cash.
And whoever bought it agreed to more terms
which included no access to the lower level,
where there is a person or persons living
with no lease in place.
This sounds like the beginning
of a horror movie I will never watch.
This is terrifying.
Yeah, that's really scary.
I mean listen, when moved to LA,
my friend Casey was in this apartment that I moved into.
We had two people.
Casey and I were sleeping in a bed together.
And then one of our best friends slept
in a tent in the kitchen,
just in a little tent
Was it some of the most fun you've ever had too?
Oh, it was a blast.
And we often had gentleman collars over,
and I would see random men
in the morning crawling out of the tent.
Yeah, so I deeply relate to this story.
You gotta do what you gotta do.
Pop a tent in your kitchen and have at it.
(upbeat music)